he is part of NBC's Super Bowl 52
pregame coverage that begins at noon
Eastern he won it as a player he wanted
as a coach he is a pro Football Hall of
Famer and I am honored to emcee
tonight's legends for charity dinner
that supports st. Jude Children's
Research Hospital he is the Pat
Summerall Award winner for this year's
Super Bowl he's Tony Dungy good to see
you sir hey Ritz it's good to be with it
I'm glad to rescue you one of a kind you
arrived in the nick of time what does it
mean to be in this city in this state
you're wearing your golden gophers I am
right now I am great memories for me
here I came here as a 17 year old
freshman had never really been out of
the state of Michigan before and had an
unbelievable time here going to school
for four years and then came back and
coached for Denny green for four so some
awesome memories here for me so now I've
asked you this off air but I can't wait
to ask you this now you're on the rich
answer Joe how did both Schembechler not
get you in a Michigan Wolverine uniform
very funny I grew up almost equidistant
between Michigan and Michigan State I
was on the Michigan campus all the time
my dad graduated from Michigan he's the
biggest U of M fan ever a mom went to
Michigan State so I had that kind of
household tension and I played
basketball I loved basketball is my
favorite sport Bo Schembechler said I
could play quarterback but didn't want
his quarterbacks playing another sport
not playing basketball anyway so that
just a little bit of a cloud there and I
ended up coming to Minnesota and it was
it worked out fancy was Johnny or
recruiting Johnny or coach campy Russell
I mean Green 76 they made the finals
yeah no I had some great players I
always visualized myself playing with
those guys and I ended up you know
coming where I had a chance to play I
played one year football and basketball
then it got to be too much boat was
right it's tough to do as a quarterback
and a basketball player was Winfield
Dave Winfield
be Hagen that Michigan Minnesota just
won the Big Ten championship when I was
in high school it was an awesome
atmosphere up here for basketball Cal
stole my football coach ed coached at
Michigan State he was Duffy Daugherty's
ace you know number-one assistant he got
the job up here he knew my high school
coach and Tom Moore who ended up
coaching for me and Indy Tom was the
offensive coordinator at Minnesota he
recruited me woody wouldn't Hoffer who
was longtime Steelers linebacker coach
he recruited me also so just some great
people and it was a great decision for
me it really was was McHale here too
Kevin McHale came after Kevin McHale
Michael Thompson all those guys were
followed me but you were on the campus
is the same time as Dave Winfield was on
contain they were all seniors okay when
I got recruited they were seniors okay I
came in then we recruited Michael
Thompson Kevin McHale mark over ding Rae
Williams yeah we had some great great
basketball teams then and I was glad to
be part of it I scored about 15 points
as a freshman total yeah that was my
basketball career all right I was about
to say cuz that I'm just doing the math
my head that's that's a almost as much
as levar ball I think I was probably
scored more points than levar okay my
best Tony Dungy here on the Rich Eisen
show so what does it mean for you to win
this Summerall award here tonight it is
such a prestigious event if the Super
Bowl here in Minnesota of all places
with NBC broadcasting the game now the
Lord's just worked this out rich a
perfect storm the Pat Summerall award
what he meant and what he did as a
broadcaster what he did as a person and
then this whole thing benefiting st.
Jude and I get selected the year that
it's in my second home state of
Minnesota we're broadcasting the game
and I know what this is going to do for
st. Jude's Hospital and the research I
have a son a 17 year old that has some
congenital issues he's been in and out
of the hospital a lot of surgeries and
trying to find cures for those
situations I know what parents go
through so it's a doubly special for me
and really looking forward to tonight
yeah and you go ahead and Google Legends
for charity and if you're in the area go
ahead and get some tickets and if not
you need to go ahead and donate st. Jude
Children's Research Hospital it is it's
really it's the only event at the Super
Bowl held every year where dignitaries
all come together in honor of one
specific charity and it's it's a great
one obviously and you are very well
deserving it well I'm sure that's gonna
be awesome it'll be great and it won't
be my pleasure to emcee that and get you
out to your next destination it's
broadcast the game exactly get to do
that so what do you think of this game
Tony where do you stand on Super Bowl 50
to Friday's out I think it's gonna be a
lot better game than people think
everybody's looking at New England and
their dynasty and their history and the
fact that they're so experienced they've
been here before Philadelphia New Kids
on the Block and without their starting
quarterback but I was in Philly for the
last two playoff games and then three
days with their players doing features
there's a spirit on that team a belief
they feel good about themselves and to
me they have the same formula not saying
they're gonna win this game but you look
at the Giants two Super Bowl wins
excellent front for that could rush the
pass or without blitzing tough physical
teams that could run the ball and a
quarterback who made plays at the right
time and I think Philadelphia has all
that is I think it's gonna be a great
game yeah and and what what what advice
would you give Doug Peterson as he
enters his first Super Bowl what would
you pass along to him Tony well it's
funny you say that because when we went
in Super Bowl 41 I called Andy Reid Bill
Cowher Mike Homer and the guys that I
knew that had been to Super Bowls
recently tell me what it's like and
every one of them said you've got to get
your team to relax the moment is going
to be big but they've got to enjoy the
journey and everything takes longer
Super Bowl week you're here longer
you've got more things going on warm-ups
and longer
half times longer but the the playing
the game the 60 minutes is still the
same so try to get your team to focus on
that enjoy the moment let them relax and
I think Philadelphia is doing that to a
great extent now they've they've got a
big problem because New England knows
how to play these big games and that
that's gonna be the key is the moment
the bright lights if they can handle it
I think it's gonna be a great game well
how did you get the culture to relax
well the first thing I told them is
we're not gonna start thinking football
too early we had our media day on
Tuesday and then our first practice in
Miami on Wednesday so I said hey Monday
& Tuesday I don't even want to know what
you're doing there's no curfew Edgerrin
James and Reggie Wayne we're from Miami
I said you got them Wow don't tell me
where you're going
oh don't nobody go to jail Wow I don't
want to know what you did
uh-huh just relax and have fun Wednesday
morning we'll start thinking football
and and they did Ezrin I did something I
don't know what do you know to this day
to this day I don't know would you like
to know I would love to know might have
Reggie Wayne sometimes you could ask
he's part of NFL Network I cannot wait
to ask him but they had fun and then we
zeroed in and tried to do everything
Wednesday Thursday Friday just as we
would on a normal game week mmm ask Tony
Dungy the poll question because
interestingly enough we had amadon in
this hour we had Dion on in this hour
and Dion and Emin are part of the teams
that are mentioned as is Tony Dungy who
won with the Steelers of the 70s have
attic Kris Brockman yeah Tony what's the
greatest NFL dynasty the Packers
Steelers Niners Cowboys or this version
of the Patriots you know the longevity I
think this is Steelers 74 75 76 77 78
the best team you you know you look at
the Hall of Famers right and how they
did it and the competition that we
played where you had to beat Oakland and
Miami and Dallas and those teams were
loaded and - those just were some great
teams but a 17-year run from 2001 to
2007
Dean that's hardened nobody's done that
you know Otto Graham and Paul Brown and
the 50s and they won for a decade and
the steel is one for a decade the
Packers won for a decade you know but to
two decades in the free agency era as
well that I mean just staying at the top
and and Tom Brady and Bill Belichick I
know we'll talk about them a lot this
week but to say hey we've won three
times we won fourth we've won five times
but I still want to come in tomorrow and
I'm motivated to be the best football
player in the National Football League
I'm motivated to be the best coach after
we've already won five that that's
unbelievable yeah I know I'm getting to
do what I do for a living with the NFL
Network outside of this being at the
Hall of Fame every every year meeting
Mel Blount he looks like he could give
me 10 15 20 snaps tomorrow and I see how
big he is he was bigger than Bruce Smith
standing next to him and I'm like no
wonder they changed the rules for this
first person I met in the National
Football League I'm an undrafted rookie
I get off the plane in Pittsburgh the
guy gives me a little ticket get on the
bus and go to the William Penn hotel so
I'm on the bus by myself I get off I'm
looking around and no don't know where
to go and I'm in the lobby and this guy
comes up to me looks like he's 7 foot
tall cowboy hat on yeah just strapped
and he says oh you must be you know go
up here did you get your key on the 10th
floor and he said I'm Mel Blount and I
said this is a cornerback is gonna be
different
boy he was and still to this day I mean
he rides horses he works on the farm he
he proud my last year or his last year
playing he was 35 years old and coach
know used to run 40s every year he ran
for for 7 his last year in the league at
35 years old and he told me I was
coaching that I I'm played and retired
and coaching he ran for 47 he said I'm
slowing down I think this is gonna be my
last year did he run with the cowboy hat
I mean unbelievable every time I saw
like no wonder they changed the rules
yes did you met I mean obviously you can
imagine you saw Tony I loved working
with you this past year I know Thursday
Night Football is gone somewhere else
it's been a pleasure doing that I hope I
got to do it again very soon
I can't wait to emcee the big night
tonight it's an honor for me to do that
finisher Ritz and I wouldn't have
anybody else do it but but you it's
gonna be special I appreciate that and I
can't wait to tell Dan Patrick that when
I see Tony Dungy on Twitter Dan doesn't
have Michigan roots like so we can
tolerate him but we'll never be brother
you and me Tony Dungy here on the Rich
Eisen show the Rich Eisen show weekdays
at noon eastern on audience